well cake cane is cool you're a female
Bruce Wayne awesome hilarious Hanson
I really no I just I when I think about
it I think about the pilot and it was
emotional you know this is a lot in it
because we want to set it up in a way
that tells a lot of the story before we
get into it and so for me it's like
she's been through a lot
she's a very strong woman she's got a
lot of nuances she's got a lot of things
about her that I think people will
identify with and then she's yeah she
has a moment that she has to make a
decision and decided who she wants to be
and what she wants to be and I think
it's really powerful to see them on TV
I need you to fix his suit the suit is
literal perfection it will be when it
fits a woman
honestly shooting the pilot was so much
fun but I just was really really hurting
he would get picked up because it's a
phenomenal shark my character is amazing
my cast is amazing the backs or is it
beautiful it's late it's deep it just
should be her oh sure but it's really
grounded and I relate to the character
so much I just I think it's a show that
people are gonna really enjoy so I guess
I'm most excited for people to watch it
they think on him
[Music]
I'm not about to let a man take credit
for a woman's work